the people of Portland and Dorset are
angry
protest group gathered to oppose
government plans to house hundreds of
migrants not far from here we don't know
who these people are all I know is that
we've heard that it's 500 men
the immigration barged the baby
Stockholm is heading their way soon to
be home to around 500 Asylum Seekers
docked just off the coast
same time these protesters said the plan
was inhumane a message back to the home
office which at the moment I think it's
too late we can't stop the badge what
were you saying no to the badge and yes
the refugees
this country was built on immigration
Friday saw the highest number of
migrants arriving into the UK after
crossing the channel in a single day so
far this year more than 600 men women
and children risked their lives to reach
Britain's Shores
stopping the boats is now one of the
prime minister's key priorities and to
cut the eye-watering 6.8 Million Pound a
Day hotel bill for housing Asylum
Seekers the government plans to use
former military bases and airfields like
this one in Wethersfield in Essex
[Applause]
similar protests here from residents who
say they're worried about what it means
for them this is very much rural ethics
you tend to know most people who are in
the village
so if a group of five or six strangers
came up to me it wouldn't matter what
color creed whatever
not recognizing any of them
it will raise my adrenaline labels a bit
wrong place
current migration policy is causing
Rising tensions in areas like these
but fair weather means more migrants
will come what the UK does with them
once here is becoming an increasingly
divisive and controversial issue Nick
Martin Sky News